>>commentator: Thanks everyone for coming
today and for dialing in. Today we have the
next installment in the Authors@Google series
and I'm very pleased to present Angela Saini.
Angela is an award winning science journalist
who writes for the New Scientist, Wide, and
GQ. She's also a regular reporter for the
BBC including the Digital Planet program.
"Geek Nation" is her first book. It's just
been released to great reviews in Europe.
It is coming out in Asia next week, and we
just found out that it's gone to number four
in the India bestsellers list today even pre-release
so. It's coming out in the U.S. shortly but
if you didn't pick up the book on the way
in, you can pick one up Amazon or on the Kindle.
Angela's based in London but she's flown in
from New York to be with us today. So thank
you very much for coming. Without further
ado, Angela Saini.
[applause]
>>Angela Siani: This is a really small audience
but I'm cheered by the fact that millions
of YouTube listeners will be watching it.
Yes.
My book launched a month ago and I have done
quite a few talks since then but never to
a very techy audience. So if this way below
your I.Q. level, please tell me and I'll speed
it up and I'll find something more interesting
to talk about.
I didn't really know what to talk about. "Geek
Nation covers" so many themes. Each chapter
is a self contained story in its own right
and there's an overarching narrative that
goes on top of it. So it's very difficult
to pick out stories and have them make sense
or pick out things and have them make sense.
But one of the things that people always say
to me especially if they've visited India
or they've lived in India, is, "India is such
a poor country. How is it possible that this
could be a nation of geeks? How can it be
possible that you are calling it an aspiring
scientific superpower? There's a huge paradox
there." So that's what I want to talk about
today and I want to try and communicate to
you this idea that even though India is poor
and has high rates of illiteracy and poor
education, it can still have the potential
of entering the ranks of a scientific giant.
And, also at the same time, my book doesn't
have any pictures in it and people have said
they would love to be able to see pictures
of the places I'm describing so that's -- I'm
gonna give you a chance to have a look at
some of the places that I talk about.
So there is this weird thing that India is
this eleventh largest economy and yet it is
still, it still has very high rates of illiteracy.
So it actually has more illiterate adults
than there are people in the U.S. which kind
of puts that in perspective, while at the
same time having this huge population of scientists
and engineers.
So I wanted to start by putting some kind
of perspective for you on the culture, the
culture of geekiness that I believe exists
in India. So the picture on the slide right
now is of Viswanathan Anand who is an Indian
chess champion, actually world chess champion.
And India loves chess. It has this huge passion
for chess and so I want to start just by reading
an extract from the beginning of the book
in Chapter 1 where I go to this chess tournament
in Delhi and I try to figure out why it is
that Indian's love chess so much.
"So the country is ranked fourth globally
in the sport and chess players insist it is
a sport above the United States which is ninth."
Which gives you some perspective on how brilliant
India really is at chess.
"But there's something more unusual about
this scene in the chess tournament. Generally
India is not a sporting nation. In fact apart
from cricket and a handful of other games,
chess is a rare exception in a land that has
one of the worst sporting records of anywhere
in the world.
Take the Olympics, for example. In the history
of the modern games the United States has
won 2,549 medals. Great Britain has won 737,
and China 429. Even the small Eastern European
nation of Belarus has taken home 73. But you
have to scroll almost to the bottom of the
league tables to find India. It sits just
above the desolate central Asian republic
of Mongolia and just below Slovakia. In the
whole of the Olympics history, India has won
only 20 medals. Given the country's vast population,
it's a mystery that's confused sports writers
for decades.
So a few years ago, two U.S. researchers,
Anirudh Krishna from the Stanford Institute
of Public Policy at Duke University and Eric
Haglund from the Congressional Hunger Center
decided to investigate. A country of more
than a billion people like India they calculated
should have won 157 medals at the 2004 Olympic
games. But, of course, this fails to take
into account that elite sports are expensive,
ruling out millions of Indians who would never
have a hope of becoming professional athletes.
Wealth and size aren't the only things that
determine Olympic success either. There's
also the general level of education, people's
health, and how close they live to sporting
facilities. So the researchers crunched the
numbers again. Taking into account the myriad
factors that determine sporting success, they
came up with a formal conservative estimate.
India should have won around 14 medals at
the 2004 Olympic games they said."
Does anyone know how many they actually won?
[pause]
It was one.
>>voice in audience: [unintelligible]
"And in fact no other nation in their study
had such a huge gap between its predicted
medal count and the actual total. 'India did
not and does not have a sporting culture,'
the veteran Indian sports columnist Rohit
Brijnath explains to me frankly. Today he
works with The Straits Times newspaper in
Singapore after the Indian sports magazine
he was writing for closed down. 'Personally
one of the things I always felt as a sports
writer was a lack of drive among many athletes.
I can't understand it. It is much better now
but earlier you only found that drive here
and there in exceptions like the great 400
meter runner of the 1960's Milkha Singh who
used to boast that he trained so hard that
he used to pee blood. My theory and it's just
mine' he adds 'is that we're better suited
to hand eye sports like shooting or billiards
or archery or thinking sports like chess.
I turned to Radisham Tuari, a 64 year old
international arbiter for the World Chess
Association, for his opinion. He's been playing
this game for 40 years. Watching the players
on the table next to us, he ponders the question
for awhile. 'Indians well basically they have
a good liking for brainy games,' he announces
at last rolling each R with his tongue. 'Yes,
and we are good at brainy things,' he continues.
'Brain makes us supreme.'"
That kind of sums up the attitude that Indians
have to science and technology and academic
pursuits. This idea that sport, physical sport,
isn't really necessary in order to move the
nation forward even though it might be a nice
indicator of a kind of show of how much of
a superpower a country is, but what really
will take them forward is academic games:
chess and if you look at the Olympiads which
unlike the Olympics are a kind of a academic
contest that happen around the world among
students, India actually does really well.
It's one of the champions in that.
And so one of the things I wanted to figure
out when I wrote "Geek Nation" was where does
this apparent love of brainy games comes from?
Why India? And why Asia as well?
India actually has a very long scientific
history. I'm just gonna give you a quick,
really quick overview now. India has a very
long scientific history as well as having
some of the world's leading philosophers two
thousand, one thousand years ago. It was the
place where the zero was invented which you
guys will probably know is a linchpin of modern
mathematics, it's very important to modern
maths. It was also a big center of philosophy.
The picture on the screen right now is of
the Bakhshali manuscript which is the oldest
scientific text ever found in Asia and it
was found in a farm in what is now Pakistan
but obviously used to be India once. And I
spent a really long time when I was there
trying to dig behind the history. There's
not that much of it in the book, but just
out of personal interest, I really wanted
to figure out where are these texts and where
do they lie. A lot of them have been destroyed
over the years. And the Bakhshali manuscript
oddly turned out not to be in India anymore
at all. One hundred years ago it was moved
to Oxford which is where I studied so I had
to go back to the UK in order to see it. And
very kindly the library at my old college
let me in and let me see the manuscript. It's
beautiful. What you can see here is exactly
what it looks like, this kind of faded palm
leaf manuscript, a little shred. But you can
see, not so much on this one but on the shred
that I saw you can see numbers in columns
and little groupings everywhere and different
signs, which just goes to show that before
the West had even encountered these quite
sophisticated mathematical ideas and scientific
ideas, countries like India and China already
had them. The problem was, just like the Bakhshali
manuscript, they all moved West and they didn't
stay in the East and the East didn't really
take advantage of them like they could have,
and science and technology instead rose in
the West which is why we have the situation
that we have now.
India never went through an enlightenment
like Europe did. It never went through a Renaissance
like Europe did. And it wasn't India that
took advantage of advances, those early advances
in science and tech. It was a royal society
in London that was one of the places that
became the arena for the development of modern
science as we understand it today. So this
idea that you can make a hypothesis, test
it empirically, and then subject it to peer
review, which is what we think of science
now, that was not what science looked like
a thousand, two thousand years ago.
So India kind of exists in this strange scientific
limbo because it hasn't completely separated
these ideas of the past with modern science.
It is re [bad audio] pseudoscience and astrology
and homeopathy and ideas that in the West
where we've ditched to some extent or at least
we don't treat them like we treat modern science.
In India, they sit almost side by side.
So, for example, I sent to the Indian Science
Congress last year in January which is the
biggest scientific meeting in India and the
Prime Minister comes, lots of ministers. And
in the exhibition hall, there were pamphlets
on Vedic Science and Vedic Science is a type
of religious, Hindu religious science and
astrology and there were panels on homeopathy.
So there is this, it does exist in this strange
limbo and it's been difficult to get out of
it because that Renaissance period never happened,
but they have tried.
And so now I want to go much forward in time
and back about 60 years when India became
independent from the British.
So India's first Prime Minister, after the
country became independent from the British
in 1947, was Jawaharlal Nehru. And these days,
we always think of Nehru as this kind of charismatic,
cool leader who was a bit of a ladies' man
and built this entire nation from scratch
after the British left India. But he was also
a geek in his own right. He studied natural
sciences at Cambridge and when he became Prime
Minister of India, he had seen what had happened
in the U.S. and he'd seen what happened in
the Soviet Union and said to himself, "I want
a part of that for India. Science and technology
is the way we are going to grow this country.
And we have to do it not just by investing
in science and tech but also by making the
population more rational." So it was almost
a call to enlightenment -- not quite because
it was many hundreds of years later. But his
legacy was so huge that if you look at the
Indian Constitution now, it says on the slide,
"One of the fundamental duties of an Indian
citizen is to develop the scientific temper,
humanism, and the spirit of inquiry and reform,"
which is unique in constitutions around the
world. We can't even imagine that now, that
all those decades ago, Indian leaders would
have looked at the country and said, "This
is a birthplace of four major world religions,
a very spiritual nation, yet we have to make
the country more rational and logical in the
way it thinks. Even if you're not a scientist
in your everyday life, we want you to be more
logical."
So Nehru carried this kind of legacy forward
and it was a button that was picked up by
subsequent leaders, every single one. So he
founded these huge Indian institutes of technology
which today many of the people who graduated
from there in 1970s and 1980s have come to
Silicon Valley and San Francisco, have set
up huge firms. So Sun Microsystems, for example,
was founded by Vinod Khosla who's an IIT graduate.
And many of India's IT leaders and politicians,
technocrats, are IIT graduates. He also founded
nuclear power stations, hydroelectric dams;
he invested in labs and research facilities.
So he really laid or helped to lay the foundation
for what we now think of as more of a nation
of geeks.
But then the question is, given this kind
of geeky culture that exists and given this
investment on the government's side into science
and technology, what exactly today are we
seeing in terms of results? So how far is
India really at becoming a scientific superpower?
That was a big question for me. I'm a, I mean
I'm a science journalist, I work mainly in
the UK, and I was skeptical when I went to
India because a lot of people have said to
me, "You won't even find enough examples of
original Indian science to fill your book.
There's not much going on there."
So one of the first things I did when I landed
in New Delhi, that was in the winter of 2009,
was I knew the first thing had to be that
I had to visit one of these Indian institutes
of technology to see what they're like on
the inside. Are they really these hotbeds
of exciting innovation or are they just perpetuating
the stereotype that Indian engineers are kind
of geeky, drone-like, and a bit boring and
dull?
So the picture on the slide here is inside
the geek factory, the Indian Institute of
Technology in Delhi. The photographs that
you're going to see now, the next three slides
were taken by Tom Parker who is a Conde Nast
photographer. I did a piece for GQ at the
same time as visiting the IIT and these are
pictures that he took. And they're a perfect
glimpse into how these places look.
This especially: it's a dusty window or a
board where a guy is writing on and you can
see a kind of shabby lecture theater in the
background, and that's exactly what this place
is like. They're really shabby. I was kind
of disappointed at turning up to this, what
is meant to be the most elite engineering
college in the whole of India, and it didn't
have air conditioning in most of the lecture
theaters which meant that in the summer, these
kids boil to death and yet they still have
to turn up to lectures.
And worse than that, worse than the shabbiness
and the old fashioned lecture theaters and
the lack of air conditioning, there really
didn't seem to be, on the surface at least,
any kind of spirits of creativity. I mean
I studied engineering and when I was there,
one of my classmates built a computer in his
spare time. When I was a kid, I used to build
model rockets and engineers are natural tinkerers
and there didn't seem to be this quality among
the Indian, young Indian engineers that I
was meeting at the Indian Institute of Technology.
And that kind of disappointed me, although
it did reinforce the stereotype and it did
confirm it.
So I tried to figure out, why is it? Why is
it that these kids choose to do engineering
and yet they don't seem to have a passion
for it? And part of the reason is that the
education system is so competitive.
So in 2009, almost half a million Indian students
sat the engineering college entrance exams
and only 10,000 of them got a place, which
just goes to show -- that's harder to get
into than Harvard, Oxford, Cambridge, any
of the big universities in the West -- which
just goes to show how difficult and competitive
these places are. And so in order to win a
place like that, in order to pass the exams,
these kids spend every evening and every weekend
in coaching classes. So almost all the students
at this Indian Institute of Technology will
have been coached almost entirely through
their teenage years and by the time they get
to college, they're burnt out, understandably.
That passion has been sucked out of them,
if you like. They're literally spending their
childhoods cramming for these exams.
And this, the picture on the slide right now
is of a kid called Nishant Ranka. He's 22
years old, an engineering student, and he
said to me, "When I went to the UK and saw
people shut their shops at five o'clock, I
couldn't understand it. Here they're open
late into the night. Indians work a lot, lot
harder than Europeans and Americans." And
he told me that he was coached before he came
to college for three hours a day as well as
the nine hours he would study anyway at school
to make sure he passed the exams.
And the pressure is so immense that the National
Crime Records Bureau which keeps a check of
suicides, the suicide rate across India, in
2008, which is their most recent figure, more
than 2,000 students across India committed
suicide because of the pressure of exams and
the fear that they would fail.
So this, the growth in IT has lead to the
demand for engineers, has led to thousands
more kids wanting to go to college to study
engineering, but has also lead in turn to
this kind of [BAD AUDIO] is stifled because
of the competition and because it's so difficult
to get into these places. But that is changing,
and it was only after spending many weeks
there that I noticed how these tiny little
shoots of innovation are coming up now.
So the next slide is of, is still inside the
Indian Institute of Technology. In 1991, so
when Nehru became Prime Minister of India
he was very much a socialist. He believed
that India had to be self sufficient, had
to do everything itself. He didn't believe
in foreign imports, not only of objects but
also ideas. In 1991, that began to change;
India liberalized its economy. I'm sorry this
is a really potted history, it's really quick
[laughs] and I hope you're keeping up with
it.
So in 1991, the economy liberalized. MTV came
in, Coca-Cola came in, but also with that
was this kind of influx of new ideas, foreign
ideas. It was easier to travel. Everybody
saw more of the world, and this new generation
came up. A guy at Tata Consultancy Services
which is one of Indian's big three IT firms
called it "Generation WHY." So not Generation
XY but Generation W-H-Y, the first generation
post-liberalization who are willing to question
and not just do rote learning or not just
cram for exams but think outside the box a
bit.
And at the IIT in Delhi, I wanted to find
evidence of that and luckily, fortunately
I did. It's beneath the surface and it's only
just beginning to happen now which makes sense
if you think about it because the 22 year
olds of now are the ones who have grown up
in this post-liberalization age, post-1991.
So the student in the slide right now took
part in a contest called the Rubicon which
is a big Pan-Asian event where students have
to come together and build a robot that can
do one specific human task. So things like
this are happening. There's also this new
group on campus called "Technocracy" which
in their spare time they're learning things
like MATLAB which is a venturing programming
language and they're learning to build microprocessors.
So there's tiny, creative shoots that are
coming up right now. It's very small and in
the six months I spent researching this book,
I did find tiny examples of this innovation
happening all over India, but it's very small
and it's very much at the beginning of a revolution,
if you like.
And I think the reason we still carry the
stereotype that we do about the Indian engineers
reminds me a lot of how we saw Japan in the
1970s, 1960s and 70s: that here is this country
that is really good at copying what other
people are doing, but not so good at coming
up with its own ideas. And India is in that
state now, but just crossing the line in the
same way that Japan did. So these kids who
are now graduating, who have only lived in
a liberalized India, are going to be the ones
that think outside the box and create this
new innovative society -- the kind of society
that you have in San Francisco and Silicon
Valley that is truly scientific and creative.
So what are they actually achieving in scientific
terms? Now given that this generation hasn't
completely come of age yet, it's a bit difficult,
but one example that I talk about in the book
is tuberculosis. So research into tuberculosis
is quite wide spread in India. It's a disease
that kills two Indians every three minutes.
So it's incredibly deadly, incredibly contagious.
In the West, we haven't heard of it so much
or it's not so prevalent just because it's
almost been eradicated here. And it is a function
of poverty. It's a function of poor health
and poor diet and low immunity, and in India,
it's a huge problem.
The picture on the slide right now is of a
tuberculosis clinic in Mumbai and a poor guy
being, having his chest examined by a doctor.
Now I didn't go to Mumbai. I actually went
to Chennai to visit some TB hospitals. And
Chennai, if you don't know already, is India's
medical capital. It's so great at medicine.
It has some of the best hospitals in the world,
so good in fact that medical tourists go from
the West to have their hips replaced and kidneys
replaced there at rock bottom prices, and
they can stay in a fancy hotel while they're
doing it. But of course that's not where the
poor go. The poor end up in places like this
and they're the majority.
So here is a deadly disease killing millions
of Indians and millions in the developing
world. Western pharmaceutical companies haven't
come up with a cure for TB in 40 years, a
new treatment in 40 years, which means that
if you have TB, you need to take a cocktail
of drugs for six months in order to fix it
and even then, you're not guaranteed of not
being contagious. And while you are contagious,
the chances are you will infect many dozens
of people around you.
So the reason that big pharma don't invest
in TB is like I said it's not a disease prevalent
in the West, there's not that much money for
it. But in India, what they're doing is all
these disparate researchers with very small,
with a very small amount of resources and
in very ramshackle labs, are trying to work
on it. So I visited one researcher, for example,
in Chennai who has a lab that's so unbiosafe,
has such poor resources, that you can't even
work on the TB bacterium itself because it's
too dangerous. She has to work on E. coli
which is the closest to TB that she can get
and do studies on safely for her team.
So what's the solution? Given that you have
all these poor but willing researchers all
over India working on this drug, on this bug
and trying to come up with a solution and
yet they don't have the resources of big pharma.
And this is what may be the solution. It's
the Open Source Drug Discovery Project and
it's run out of Delhi. It's, the government
funds it, the Indian government funds it partly
with a very, when you compare it to how much
it would cost big pharma to produce a drug
for TB, a fraction of the cost. And what they're
essentially doing, they call it Science 2.0
and what they're essentially doing is collecting
all the TB research from all over the country
and putting it online and trying to make sense
of it in a way that might help lead to a TB
drug later down the line.
One of the things that they're trying to do
is annotate the TB genome, and if anyone knows,
this is a long process. It's basically explaining
how the TB genome works and how it's built
and it can take many months to do it. But
given that they had all these researchers,
disparate researchers the OSDD team got together
and said, "How about if we ask Indian students
to each take a small section of the genome
and annotate it?" So that's what they did.
They got thousands of students from all over
the country, obviously post-grad and qualified
students because it's not an easy, it's a
specialized job. And yet because of Indian's
vast geeky manpower, they can do this. And
they got them all together and within a few
months they had annotated the genome, which
is incredibly quick. They still have to verify
it and check it and make sure that it's all
fine, but as a model for doing very fast biology
it's incredibly efficient.
And companies have been so excited about it.
One Indian IT company, Emphasis, has offered
to give their expertise for free. So they're
offering to design a semantic Web platform
where all this research can be made sense
of so that they can use it to develop a new
drug. And they're fairly confident they will
develop a new drug out of it.
So when I met the team, which was last spring,
2,700 people in India and overseas had registered
to be part of the group. And when I was writing
out the chapter -- from 53 different countries,
when I was writing up the chapter a few months
later that had gone up to 3,800 in 93 countries.
So if you look at this, India is a poor country
and yet in an innovative way, it's overcoming
the fact that it has resource shortfalls by
taking advantage of its huge geeky manpower
and coming up with alternatives. This is completely
antithetical to the way science works.
Science, especially pharmaceutical science,
is about credit. It's about keeping research
maintained within a small company or a small
group so that you can make sure that you own
it at the end. And yet, these thousands of
scientists are willing to give up their credit
or share their credit, dilute it and work
together in order to come up to a solution
to a problem like this. Science isn't done
this way and it's interesting and I think
it shows a measure of innovation in India
that they came up with a solution like this
and that it is working.
And it's not just pharmaceuticals or obvious
areas like biological research or medicine
where things like this are happening. The
government, in the vein of Nehru's vision
for India to be a more scientific society,
are also trying to harness that geeky manpower
to improve the country as a whole. And to
illustrate that, I want to read another extract
from the book. This is the last one. It's
from a chapter called "Geeks Rule" and it's
about a city being built in the Western Ghats.
There's a picture of the Western Ghats behind
me. This an enormous range of hills just a
few hours' drive from Pune -- that's the nearest
city -- but quite isolated, very few people
live there.
"So the ground beneath our feet is always
moving. Two hundred million years ago South
America, Africa, India, Australia, and Antarctica
weren't where they are now but were part of
one enormous supercontinent that spanned the
hemisphere. The split happened around thirty
million years later, after which they gradually
drifted into positions they occupy today.
When this violent breakup happened, gigantic
volcanic ranges burst through the crust while
vast new oceans filled the gaps that the shifting
continents left behind. The earth looked like
a pie that had been torn into slices. At its
edges, the land buckled and creased. In the
north of India, the Himalayas were created
and when Indian's west coast finally broke
free from the island of Madagascar, another
one of these geological creases became the
Western Ghats.
Today, this 1,600 kilometer stretch of high
hills, blanketed in forest, is one of the
most remote places in the world. There are
at least 5,000 different types of flowers.
Elephants, snakes, tigers, and cave bats all
live here, secluded from the rest of India.
Zoologists who have occasionally ventured
into the Ghats have found new species by the
handful. One time they discovered a dozen
multi-colored types of frog, a species that
was thought to have been extinct for a century.
The mountainous territory is inhospitable.
The second I cross into it civilization disappears.
It's eerily silent in every direction, save
a cry from the odd makak.
And yet here in the middle of the Western
Ghats, in what can reasonably be called 'nowhere'
I descend into a steep valley and find myself
in one of the most advanced cities on earth.
I arrive in the evening, just in time to catch
dinner at one of the first restaurants in
this half built metropolis. It's an American
style diner and I'm their only customer. There
are pictures of Lucille Ball and Betty Boop
on the walls and the floor is covered in black
and white checkerboard tiles.
When they bring my food, they slide bottles
of French's yellow mustard and Heinz tomato
ketchup onto the countertop of my red leather
booth. This could be New York in the 1950s.
But this isn't the Twilight Zone, this is
a city of Lavasa.
I first read about it in an advertisement
in an in-flight magazine and became intrigued
by what the advert claimed would be a metropolis
governed mainly by machines. A bank of centralized
computers, I read, will control everything
here from household security to the transport
network. It's a half billion dollar project
to build from scratch an urban dream in the
middle of the mountains. Even the roads leading
here have had to be carved out of the hills.
It's the biggest thing to happen to the Western
Ghats since the cretaceous period."
So you can imagine how weird it was for me
to turn up, to drive for two hours in the
night and then turn up in the middle of a
hill and be eating omelets in an American
diner [laughs] with pitch black all around
me and nobody there because the workers had
gone home and nobody has moved into the city
yet.
So the interesting thing about this place,
like I said, is that it will be electronically
governed -- that's the aim. It's completely
being built from scratch. So what they've
done is during the construction they've mapped
everything in layers. So everything from the
water pipes to where the houses are, the foundations,
the broadband, everything has been designed
so that if there's a fault, they'll know exactly
where it is and they can go and fix it immediately.
And every house and apartment in this complex,
and I'll show you the complex here -- this
is a picture of the promenade at Lavasa. The
American diner is near the end. This is the
only bit that was actually complete when I
got there. So you can imagine just this and
then hills all around it.
Every apartment in there will have a kiosk
where even if you don't have access to the
Internet or your own computer, you'll be able
to use this kiosk to pay all your bills, make
complaints if you have to, communicate with
other residents. It's an Internet for the
entire city. And what the temporary manager
told me -- they're going to elect a mayor
once the city gets running -- but what the
temporary manager told me was that this city
will, the aim is to have as few people running
it as possible. Essentially it will run itself.
The geeks will rule, or the technology will
rule.
But then again, this is a private development.
It's really expensive to stay here. The houses
have almost all been sold now I think, but
the population is capped at 300,000 and if
you want to live there then you have to pay
a high price. So a lot of the people who have
bought houses I understand, are actors and
actresses and IT moguls and stuff.
But the principles that you can see here are
being rolled out across the whole of India
by the Indian government. So exactly the same
kind of thing is happening all over the country.
If you've ever been to India, you'll know
that it has very high levels of corruption
and an incredibly frustrating bureaucracy.
It holds up everything. It actually cuts to
the heart of how scientists work because the
corruption even travels as far as the university
level. So professors will get promoted because
of nepotism sometimes rather than actual merit.
So in order for India to be a smoother society,
in order for it to be any kind of superpower
let alone scientific one, it needs to solve
this problem of a weak bureaucracy and corruption.
And, of course, because it is a nation of
geeks, I think, they're digitizing everything
and that's their way of doing it -- geek government
just like in Lavasa.
So since the early 1990s, there've been these
huge state run attempts to move government
records online. This has happened all over
the world for sure. In India, though, it's
happening in such a huge way, in a way that
stunned even me. So things like land records,
birth records, birth certificates, death certificates,
are all going online and it means you can
access them more easily. And this is where
it's being masterminded.
So the picture on the screen right now is
of Electronics Niketan which is the IT ministry
of India in Delhi. "Electronics Niketan" means
an electronics house, so it's literally electronics
house.
I'm not a big fan of Indian government ministries.
Every time I've gone to one, it's been really
frustrating. You turn up. Usually they're
not there or they knock off at like three
o'clock so you miss them, huge lunch breaks.
I went to the Health Ministry many years ago
to do a story and while I was there waiting
for an official, who by the way gave me no
useful information, I got bitten by a poisonous
spider on my foot and my foot swelled up like
a sweet potato which is ironic given that
was the Health Ministry.
So I was kind of scared. I was worried about
going to this building and I left with plenty
of time, early appointment to make sure that
they would see me. And it surprised me because
it was like no ministry I'd ever been to.
I was shown in immediately. This place is
run like a well oiled machine. The second
I got there, I was told that most of the people
working there, or at least in the unit that
I was seeing, actually came from the private
sector. So they'd worked in the Indian IT
industry and now they wanted to help the government
make the country more streamlined and help
the bureaucracy, which is why they've gone
to work in this place. And it was incredible.
They answered all my questions straight away.
So one of the things they're doing in this
building is monitoring projects like Lavasa,
but also other examples of electronic governance
all over the country being run on the state
level to see where the best practice is. And
what they've come up with is a scheme very
much like in the houses of Lavasa, you'll
have those kiosks. They're introducing kiosks
like that at the block level all across India.
So a block is about five or six villages,
half a dozen villages. So every block will
have a kiosk operated by, in some states,
by women. It takes very little skill to be
able to operate a kiosk like that. And you'll
be able to pay all your bills there, everything.
So I visited, they're around I think halfway
through the scheme and, at the moment, they're
trying to get it into the very furthest reaches.
So there are some islands and there are some
states in the northeast that are very remote
and inhospitable. So they're working on that
right now.
But I went to visit one of the kiosks in Jaipur,
which is a city in Rajasthan on the tourist
trail. And I was a bit skeptical 'cause I've
grown up in Britain where IT projects always
seem doomed to failure [laughs]. They never
work and they've cost millions of pounds and
yet they never work.
And I got to this kiosk. It was a Sunday and
I expected there to be huge queues or if not
huge queues, then nobody using it or really
bad records. And it turned out that already
that Sunday hundreds of people across the
state had already used the kiosks near them
to pay their bills. I saw one guy paying three
different bills: so a power bill, a mobile
bill, and a landline bill, I think it was,
in minutes. And you can't do that. You can't
even do that in Britain. You can't go to one
place and pay all your bills in one place.
So it is quite incredible what they've managed
to achieve.
There aren't that many stats about how efficient
this program is yet because it's very early
days. But in 2008, the Ministry of IT here
did a survey that found that five out of the
ten states that had computerized their land
records by 2008 -- so that's just land records
which are the most contentious documents in
India, by the way. Many civil court suits
are about land records. Bribes in those states
had reduced, had either reduced significantly
or been completely eliminated.
Now when you take into account that, according
to Transparency International, all the households
below the poverty line in India, so these
are poor households in India, together pay
more than $200 million in bribes every year,
the potential for that is huge. If it works,
then it's huge. And I'm not saying that it
will work, but it's exciting that India is
taking those steps and making those advances
and making the investment to make it work.
The thing that's making it work, of course,
is that it has the geeky manpower. It's built
up an expertise in doing Western IT outsourcing
projects to other governments, learned those
lessons, and brought them back and are now
having those same people run the projects
themselves.
[pause]
So I'm nearly done.
The final thought I just want to leave you
with is that India, while India might not,
if you look at the stats, if you look at the
facts and figures, while it may not be making
a huge impact on scientific output at the
moment, I think India's proportion of scientific
output is something as a share of the globe's
is something like three percent at the moment;
so not incredibly encouraging. It is on the
cusp of this revolution that's happening.
They're trying to solve the problems, the
underlying problems, that will help the country
become a scientific superpower in the future.
They're creating this legion of geeks that
are going to help move that forward and I
really think this is what will give India
its edge in the next 10 or 20 years.
So if you look at scientific publications,
yes India is very low down. But when you think
that Japan, Germany, Britain, and France have
become steadily less productive since 2000
as a share of the world's output, if you look
at the graph, India's output has risen every
single year like China's, although not at
the same rate as China's. In 2008, it published
53 percent more scientific papers than on
average in each of the five years that went
before. So it's ramping up its investment
quite incredibly.
The biggest difference I think will be made
by the fact that the Indian government is
planning to ramp up its proportion of GDP
spending on R & D. So if you look at developed
countries and developing countries, developed
countries tend to spend around two percent
of GDP on R & D, so that includes, Japan actually
spends a lot more than that, U.S. spends about
that, UK spends about that. Whereas countries
like Brazil and China and South Africa -- China
is increasing but Brazil and South Africa
and India tend to spend around one percent.
The government has made a commitment to enter
that two percent category. I can't say when
that will happen; they were hoping it would
happen by next year. That's unlikely, but
it will happen soon.
The picture on the slide is of Manmohan Singh
doing a V sign, but I chose it because it
was a two, two percent. [laughs]
[laughter]
Although I'm sure that's not why he meant
when he did that.
He announced last year actually that 2012
would be India's year of science which is
great for the book, but I think also great
for India.
And so finally -- this is a very almost final
slide -- I love space rockets and it doesn't
really serve a purpose but I wanted to show
you two pictures of space rockets quickly.
[laughs]
[laughter]
The first is, I went to the Indian Space Research
Organization in the book and I saw a rocket
launch in South India which was just incredible
-- not of a rocket this scale. But the first
is a polar satellite launch vehicle which
is what carried India's first lunar probe
a couple of years ago which was a pretty good
success. And India's plan now is to send their
first astronaut into space in 2015, which
is something in terms of individual nations
only three nations have done -- that's China,
U.S., and the Soviet Union. And that astronaut
or those astronauts will go up in a rocket
something like this which is a geosynchronous
satellite launch vehicle. It'll probably be
a bit bigger than that and so they're working
on that now, working on the technology just
not, not just the rocket technology but also
making these things habitable which is actually
a huge scientific challenge.
And I think this demonstrates in terms of
space especially, demonstrate India's raw
ambition when it comes to science and that
even though people might look at India and
say, "Why is this poor country investing so
much in science and tech?" It is playing the
long game, it is thinking about the far, far
future --
[pause[
and that's it.
Thank you.
[laughs]
[applause]
Are there any questions?
Yeah.
>>male #1: [unintelligible]
>>Angela Saini: Oh yeah we need the microphone
for the question.
>>male #1: Thank you for coming. I had a couple
questions sort of related to if there's any
signs of resistance or push back ?
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: to this movement. For example when
you were speaking of Lavasa ?
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: and the sort of wide spread E-government
proposals and so forth --
>>Angela Saini: Um-hum.
>>male #1: I think that's fantastic --
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: I think that's wonderful to make
people's lives more efficient and so forth.
But I'm also thinking there's somebody out
there thinking, "Wow, that's a bureaucrat
that's not getting paid."
>>Angela Saini: [laughs]
>>male #1: Those are bribes I'm not getting.
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: And I should, if I can, derail
this as soon as possible."
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: So as an economic reason for push
back -- and the other is sort a more cultural
one and you can sort of see that here in the
United States where there's sort of the haves
and the have nots --
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: of technological progress --
>>Angela Saini: Um-hum.
>>male #1: and so forth and that has caused
something of a religious resurgence here in
the United --
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: States and other places and obviously
as you mentioned India already has this great,
impressive religious history --
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: and so I mean -- so one question
is -- is this, is this revolution going to
be equally distributed --
>>Angela Saini: [laughs]
>>male #1: both geographically, politically,
and culturally and so forth? And then again
sort of a general question about have you
seen any signs of push back ?
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: sort of on these movement forward.
>>Angela Saini: Yeah, actually about a third
of the book is about the resistance from religious
groups and activists. There are many activists
in India who believe that the country, like
Mahatma Gandhi dreamed of it, would always
be this nation of farmers, that it would always
be largely agricultural place, which is completely
at odds with this idea that you should industrialize
and it should become this nation of geeks.
And for them it will always be a nation of
farmers, I think. So yeah, that resistance
does exist.
In terms of the bribes, I mean the people
who take the bribes I think will be quite
stupid to then say, "No. We want our bribes
please don't do this." [laughs]
[laughter]
That would be quite odd, but I'm sure that
there are even in these big bureaucratic IT
projects, people skimming off the top because
that's the nature in places like this, and
I'm sure that's the nature in big IT projects
all over the world. There's always someone
skimming off the top.
But at the same time, if it increases transparency,
which is what it's doing and if reduces corruption
and bureaucracy because it reduces that distance
between the person and the government and
the modes for those people to come in and
become middlemen -- which they had before
and because of the Internet can't -- then
I think it will at least go some way to solving
that problem for sure.
What was your other question? Was there another
question?
>>male #1: Cultural aspects.
>>Angela Saini: There are, yeah. So in the
book I do give example. I mean the example
I use in the book is of the debate over GM
food. So in the U.S. we, GM food is very widely
grown. In Europe, there's a huge resistance
to it. And in India, it's kind of half and
half. So they grow BT cotton at the moment
which is resistance to boll worm and they're
trying to introduce their first BT food crop
which is an aubergine brinjal, an eggplant.
And there's been huge resistance to it partly
because of activists, partly because of the
way it's being done and it's thought to have
been controlled by commercial interests. So
whenever a new technology comes in, I think
people feel a bit reluctant about it. But
India and I think a lot of Asia actually is
surprisingly excited about the new.
So I gave a talk in New York the other day
and there was someone from South Korea in
the audience. And all the way through they
were nodding furiously, they were like, "Yeah,
my parents made me play chess as well --
[laughter]
and it was exactly like that in Korea." And
yeah there is, I mean in the West or at least
in Britain where I've grown up, there is this
kind of skepticism and fear of new things
and technology. Whereas in India not so much
I think people embrace it which is exciting.
>>male #2: How are the graduate research universities
doing? You mentioned the faculty. Are the
faculty, the research faculty improving and
is India doing anything to help that? Certainly
the undergraduates coming out of there are
fantastic ?
>>Angela Saini: Yeah.
>>male #1: but most of the top students don't
go to there for the Ph.D.s --
>>Angela Saini: No they don't. When I went
to the Indian Institute of Technology, they
complained, the dean was complaining that
very few students stay on to do Ph.D.'s and
certainly none of the good ones because they
can earn these huge massive salaries working
for IT companies and multi-nationals. So there's
just no incentive for them to do that especially
since India is not known for research. So
even if you did stay on, the facilities are
so poor and the resources are so poor that
you couldn't really make a mark. But that
is changing. So for example at IIT Delhi,
they're introducing programs now which will
help you get funding, if not from the government
or from the college then from private sources.
And providing these kinds of incentives for
students to stay on and do Ph.D.'s. I really
hope that happens because that's what you
need to build a truly scientific country and
that's where has India suffered all these
great undergraduates go to the U.S. and do
their Ph.D.'s here and contribute to America's
scientific society and not to India's. But
I'm convinced that that will change.
[pause]
[laughs]
Are we done?
>>commentator: Any questions on the VC just
before we wrap up?
[pause]
No. Okay, thanks everyone. Thanks very much,
Angela, for coming.
>>Angela Saini: Thank you.
[applause]